depuis quelques années les trottinettes
électriques sont partout et notamment à
Paris ou près de 15000 sont en libres au
service étant dit que le ministre des
Transports souhaite durcir les
conditions d'utilisation et augmenter
les amendes en cas d'infraction et que
certains mettent en avant les nombreux
accidents qu'elles peuvent provoquer
la mère de Paris est depuis 2019 vend
debout contre ses engins si j'avais pu
les interdire je les aurai interdites
bien les voir disparaître totalement de
la capitale alors pour en venir à bout
les Parisiens sont appelés ce week-end à
voter pour ou contre le maintien des
trottinettes dans le cadre d'un
référendum populaire une décision qui à
gaz de nombreuses utilisateurs
pour aller au travail c'est plus
agréable que le métro alors faut-il
interdire les trottinettes dans les
grandes villes
alors romain vous êtes le co-fondateur
de Cosmo connecté ouais Cosmo Connect
des équipements de sécurité pour vélo et
trottinette alors ce référendum c'est
très dangereux pour vous et vos
concurrents c'est peut-être une énorme
tasse oui enfin ce référendum c'est pour
est-ce qu'on veut apporter plus de
sécurité aujourd'hui dans une mobilité
ou tout le monde voilà on conduit tous à
Paris différemment il y a quelques
années on conduit à vélo ou en
trottinette aujourd'hui il y a plus de
trottinette électrique vendues en France
que de vélo et les trottinettes en
partage c'est présent dans 200 villes
alors faut-il interdire les trottinettes
dans les grandes villes et pour donner
leur avis pour vous bien sûr c'est non
c'est n'importe quoi cette histoire non
mais déjà moi je suis utilisateur comme
peut-être pas mal de gens ici dans le
public c'est une liberté et puis la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est que on a le
sentiment d'être plus libre on a pu
forcément de conduire en voiture
200 villes qui utilisent ces
trottinettes 100 000
le trajet par jour voilà et donc il y a
un vote dimanche et en fait l'idée c'est
d'essayer d'être plus proche des mairies
nous l'objectif c'est cosmos c'est
d'essayer de d'apporter plus de sécurité
de visibilité un petit peu aux
utilisateurs comme ce casque qui ouais
en fait on utilise la technologie de qui
vient de l'automobile donc on a rajouté
un système de feutre freinage des
clignotants un détecteur de chute et
l'idée en fait c'est de permettre à tout
le monde d'être plus en sécurité les
opérateurs depuis trois ans de travail
aussi pour apporter plus de sécurité
donc la réduction de la vitesse à Paris
on est à 20 km/h voire 10 km/h et voilà
et on est un an des JO donc il va avoir
quand même des millions de gens qui vont
venir de l'étranger et donc nous
aujourd'hui on est plus sur un sujet où
il faut apporter de la sécurité au
travail avec les mairies et
vous pensez qu'il faut interdit des
trottinettes moi je suis en guerre
contre le lobby des trottinettes contre
vous parce que vous
monsieur très respectueusement les
trottinettes c'est un danger public je
suis allé dans non non je suis allé dans
Paris aujourd'hui je suis resté une
heure parce qu'on parlait des
trottinettes vers la place du Châtelet
j'ai vu des dizaines de jeunes deux par
trottinette sans casque foncé j'en ai vu
sur les trottoirs qui grillent les feux
rouges vous ne respectez rien les
trottinettes plus 180 % de blessés en un
an 27 morts en 20227 morts trottinette
et hoverboard etc monsieur il faut
d'urgence interdire ça dans Paris ce
n'est plus possible oui madame déjà je
tiens salut la belle enquête de Gilles
Verdez qui a besoin de passer trois
heures à Paris pour ceux qui prennent
des trucs
moi je suis à 100% pour les trottinettes
c'est économique c'est écologique c'est
pratique à Paris c'est une année alors
oui il y a des accidents mais il y en a
aussi en voiture il y en a en vélo et à
Paris c'est déjà une année de se
déplacer en général c'est une année de
se loger ils veulent faire quoi ils
veulent que Paris soit ils veulent que
les grandes villes dans toutes les
grandes villes même les grandes villes
que ça fasse faillite que ça devient ça
devienne impossible de dire pourquoi
les trottinettes et en plus
contrairement aux VTC c'est un modèle
qui est économie uniquement viable et
qui n'exploite personne c'est les gens
qui payent et c'est pas cher on paye
rarement plus de 5 euros en trottinette
donc moi je suis à fond avec vous benime
ouais moi je rajoute je souscris à tout
ce que tu viens de dire je rajouterais
simplement que justement
aussi mais je rajoute très simplement
que moi je pense que il y a Clément
bonne qui propose de de augmenter l'âge
de passer de l'autorisation de la
relever jusqu'à 14 ans moi j'irai même
un tout petit peu plus haut plus haut 16
ans comme pour un comme pour un scooter
et moi je rendrai le casque obligatoire
il n'est pas encore obligatoire et ça
moi je rentre vraiment
de COSM qui fait donc des équipements de
sécurité pour vélo et trottinette alors
faut préciser Anne Hidalgo elle veut
seulement interdire les trottinettes en
libre-service dont l'énergie la question
bien sûr à l'interdiction mais c'est
déjà beaucoup si tu as déjà donc ça veut
dire que elle tape sur ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens parce que ceux qui ont
les moyens d'acheter une trottinette ça
coûte 2000 3000 4000 € alors que si on a
pas les moyens on peut quand même
l'utiliser en mettant juste quelques
pièces dans la machine voilà il y a
aussi quelque chose d'intéressant c'est
que aujourd'hui 30% des utilisateurs
sont des femmes et 65% d'entre elles
trouvent que la trottinette pas bon
moyen pour
sécuritaire aussi pour rentrer le soir
chez elle parce que c'est parce qu'ils
ont pas forcément de prendre un et 100%
pour vivre vous vous sentez votre casque
et votre machin c'est pour les profits
maintenant on va dire la vérité les
trottinettes c'est quoi c'est plus 35%
avec les vélos d'accidents je sais je
vais essayer de scooter que je suis
arrivé à l'hôpital ils m'ont dit
trottinette vélo depuis kaidelgo c'est
35%. c'est des coachs c'est tout ça
c'est des vieilles dames qui sont
traversées tout le temps vélo et
trottinette quoi que vous dites quoi que
vous en pensiez systématiquement pense
qu'ils ont tous les droits il ne
s'arrêtent pas au feu ils font tout ils
s'en fout ils sont écologiques ils
t'emmerde ils font ce qu'ils veulent
c'est partout c'est dégueulasse et puis
il y a ce côté aussi qui m'agace je
serai aujourd'hui c'est pas votre nom
mais ça m'agace oui au lieu d'être
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes âgées soit
soit renversé ce qui m'agace aussi c'est
qu'on est en train de rentrer dans une
société régressive alors trottinette
c'est marrant à 14 ans mais quand je
vois monsieur de 55 avec son bide et ça
sacoche sur sa trottinette comme ça tu
vois il y a pas de alors c'est une
société régressive et n'oubliez pas
n'oubliez pas que la principale les
accidents aujourd'hui c'est piétons vélo
trottinette ils en sont remplis le mec
dans l'hôpital m'avait dit heureusement
pour vous c'était pas l'été parce que on
enlève quasiment les goudrons comme ça
parce que les bombes qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ils ont ce t-shirt donc voilà vous
faites tomber les bombes pour les
accidents c'est juste des petites choses
donc je ne le fais pas
des solutions de sécurité voilà pour
optimiser je fais des casques connectés
qui permet de détecter des accidents en
temps réel et qui vont prévenir des
proches et les secours voilà qui vont
avoir un système de clignotant vous
gardez les mains sur le guidon
quand vous voulez en fait l'objectif
notre objectif dans notre société Cosmo
c'est d'essayer d'optimiser la sécurité
la visibilité de des utilisateurs 2
millions et demi vous l'avez dit
d'utilisateur de trottinette tous les
jours il n'y a pas eu d'accident mortel
monsieur Verdez cette année sur les
trottinettes en partage on partage et
aujourd'hui il remparts
en free flotting en location
il y a voilà donc 2 millions et demi de
personnes qui utilisent ces trottinettes
nous notre objectif c'est d'essayer de
dire comment on peut réduire le nombre
d'accidents et comment on peut
effectivement légiférer pour le port du
casque obligatoire comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui en Suisse comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui en Israël et notamment ces
sociétés de lime
ont imposé le port du casque dans ces
villas Delphine qui est non moi je suis
une
danse Mathieu et alors en même temps
voilà c'est pas grave et qu'est-ce que
je voulais dire
en fait et quand on
Paris en trottinette c'est formidable et
quand on vit à Paris pour pouvoir
utiliser les trottinettes et gagner du
temps c'est super c'est silencieux
ouais j'adore ça et alors je vais le
dire moi je roule pas en trottinette
j'aime être derrière c'est vrai ça c'est
intéressant
j'ai pas de trottinette mais en plus
je veux des noms je veux des noms pour
l'instant parce que voilà Raymond moi je
suis choqué par les espèces de pis froid
là qui disent non faut interdire faut
interdire pourquoi vous voulez interdire
à un progrès à un progrès faut juste
légiférer dire voilà on en fait plus sur
les trottoirs on fait attention Valérie
17 ans moi je dis 14 ans mais qui va
contrôler la police c'est là pour
contrôler comment ça qui va contrôler
mais vous pouvez
s'entendre
il veut plus de vélo non plus on apprend
là qui veut plus de vélo il veut plus de
tigre moi je roule dans Paris avec un
camion je peux te dire que les
trottinettes et les vélos les vélos je
les supportent plus ah bah voilà ils
arrivent à contresens
mais on a fait des trucs pour eux parce
qu'il faut être écolo parce qu'il faut
vivre avec son temps alors je suis pas
content parce qu'on me tape sur le rétro
de mon camion parce qu'il me plie mon
rétro à droite je suis obligé de
descendre pour le remettre le rétro j'ai
envie de le tuer le mec en vélo mais
c'est comme ça faut vivre avec son temps
et les trottinettes faut juste faire
attention de mettre des lois de mettre
des casses connectées pour faire
attention à partir de 14 ans des gants
être équipé mais vous êtes des jaloux en
vérité parce que
vous êtes des jaloux en quoi ça vous
gêne de voir des membres de 14-15 ans 16
ans ou des femmes rentrer du boulot tu
dis le mec de 50 ans
mais quand tu rentres dans une dame de
90 ans qui préfère te le dire
plein d'accident il y a eu 23 accidents
en tout et vous prenez l'exemple de la
vieille dame la vieille dame qui s'est
fait rentrer dedans c'est dans vos rêves
vous les voyez pas les accidents que
c'est pas fait rentrer dedans la réalité
quand tu rentres toute la journée dans
Paris
il y a personne qui peut appliquer la
loi vous pouvez légiférer vous vous
laissez un bordel monstre dans Paris
franchement tu as une poussette ou tu es
une personne âgée tu te prends des
trottinettes toute la journée c'est un
slalom ça tu crois que le mec en vélo
qui a mis ses deux gamins devant sa
remorque il fait pas chez le monde là
j'ai rien
kilomètre-heure là je peux pas le
doubler parce qu'il est avec ses deux
enfants en tête
toute la journée le premier carton c'est
les enfants qui tape le camion en
premier il a mis ses enfants devant lui
sale connard le problème c'est qu'on a
fait n'importe quoi on a mis la charrue
avant les on a mis la trottinette avant
les deux au lieu d'organiser la ville
pour que ce soit pas le chaos partout et
que les gens respectent le code de la
route et fasse des lois avant de mettre
les trottinettes sur le marché on a fait
l'inverse comme d'habitude on fait
n'importe quoi on fait toujours tout à
l'envers donc maintenant c'est le chaos
soit piéton dans Paris avec une
poussette ou une personne âgée c'est un
enfer de marché dans Paris dans la ville
d'abord
les trottinettes c'est juste c'est pas
adapté dans Paris c'est tout en fait je
voudrais Daniel qui est quand même la
plus concernée exactement et moi alors
ce que j'aimerais c'est que vous me
fassiez des casques mais pour les
piétons parce que là vous êtes tous en
train de parler de ces petits bobos qui
sont qui ont 2 km à faire dans leur
journée je suis désolé vous n'êtes pas
dans la vraie vie excusez-moi
pour traverser boulevard des Italiens je
veux dire que j'avais raison je me sens
en sécurité quand je traverse la route
maintenant plus sur le trottoir ça
devient un élémentalité vous ne les
changerez jamais vous pouvez mettre à
500 euros vraiment ça sera ça sera
pareil
tu regardes de partout à gauche à droite
à gauche à droite il y a un vélo une
trottinette
[Applaudissements]